screaming banging it's like a gulag I
mean it is hell on earth
it's about people that have lost
absolutely everything contact with the
outside world in some cases any hope of
ever getting outside of a small tiny
solitary confinement cell but they
haven't given up on on life I travel to
over 14 prisons around the country you
usually visit prisoners there in a small
cage like literally it's a vision of
horror and then at the same time I was
again and again completely overwhelmed
by people's humanity these people inside
can still crack a joke can get me
laughing there's a kind of unbearable
intimacy that happens in these isolation
pads you can be celled next to someone
literally for decades and never see
their face but you know exactly how many
times a day they flush their toilet when
they sleep you could hear them crying in
the night people can be sent to the hole
for something as petty as having the bag
of chips if you look at a guard the
wrong way that's insubordination 40
percent of the people that go into
solitary confinement are mentally ill
and don't deserve to be in prison in the
first place
solitary confinement attacks your
frontal lobe it's the part of your brain
that helps you make good decisions so
there are people that have no skills on
how to deal with their anger other than
through violence
that we're putting in conditions they
make them more violent and then they get
released into our streets they get
dumped on society that's what it has
inspired my work over the last six years
is to provide some kind of window into
the lives of some you know very flawed
human but often beautiful people people
that we meet on the outside people that
we don't need to throw away
you